[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité est l'ancien
président de Mauritanie Mohamed Hould
Abdelaziz merci d'être avec nous vous
avez été au pouvoir entre 2008 et 2019
vous êtes en France depuis un mois suite
à la levée de mesure restrictives
notamment de résidence surveillée parce
que vous êtes inculpé en Mauritanie
entre autres pour corruption blanchiment
d'argent enrichissement illicite pendant
vos années de pouvoir vous clamez que
c'est une veine d'État politique menée
par votre successeur Mohamed oul
razouani avant de venir à votre
situation je veux en venir à la
situation dans le Sahel à l'époque vous
aviez été un des instigateurs du G5
Sahel le G5 Sahel n'existe plus barkhane
s'en va il y a eu des coups d'État au
Mali au Burkina Faso l'arrivée des
Russes comment juger vu de la situation
dans le Sahel
continue à se développer dans la région
il prend de l'ampleur et élargit
d'ailleurs et déplacer frontières vers
d'autres pays
et la situation se complique davantage
effectivement il y a plus de vacances
qui est en train de disparaître de
mourir petit à petit feu
et notre voyons pas de solution à l'état
actuel
des choses la situation
semble c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
pour toute la région des coups d'État
celui du coup d'État au Mali deux fois
pratiquement au Burkina la même chose
les anciens fondateurs aussi
du G5 tous disparu comme vous
spoiles sont décédés soit ils ont quitté
le pouvoir soit parcours d'État soit par
le jeu
effectivement
en train de gagner oui c'est en train de
gagner du terrain et c'est de parce que
avant c'était c'était
l'épicentre du terrorisme était le nord
du Mali mais en train il est en train de
descendre vers le site vers les pays de
la gare le Burkina Faso le Togo et même
le Bénin ils sont tous châtiment par des
actions de terroristes c'est vrai que
l'approche n'a pas été la bonne entamée
en 2013 l'intervention de l'armée
française a été
efficace au départ mais il n'a pas été
continue parce que c'est finalement
terminé un coup de poisson
l'intervention
est la su stopper l'avancée du
terroristes en 2013 sauver le Mali et
même au-delà des États de la région mais
finalement
l'approche a été pratiquement biaisée
parce que un certain moment le combat
mené compte des terroristes a été arrêté
a été arrêté et les terroristes ont pu
se reprendre série saisir et ils ont
mité et il a été malheureusement décidé
de négocier avec certains d'entre eux
ils se sont réorganisés en politique a
fait l'erreur de négocier mais je pense
que c'est
l'approche qui a été faite
l'intervention était intervention de
l'armée française c'était de pouvoir
peut-être commencer à l'époque qui a
poussé vers des négociations mais
négocier avec avec
des touristes à l'origine avec des
trafiquants de drogue à l'origine c'est
ça le problème et ce sont des gens qui
ont mitté de trafiquants de drogue à
terroriste et de terroristes
et
puis a eu tort d'encourager des
négociations c'était c'était l'erreur
c'était l'erreur parce que on ne doit
pas et on ne peut pas négocier avec les
terroristes d'abord
pour moi l'utérus de la région du Sahel
et
singulièrement du Mali ce sont des
terroristes en particulier de
l'extérieur du mari donc ils sont
étrangers au Mali mais par la suite ce
sont greffés à eux des Maliens des
locaux des locaux il fallait moi je
pense que l'approche devait essayer de
scinder entre l'utérus qui sont des
nationaux et négocier avec eux et
trouver des solutions au lieu au lieu de
continuer à les combattre en armant une
partie de la population ce qui a
exacerbé un peu
une certaine Lite et interne
qui s'est répercuté d'ailleurs si les
autres pays finalement alors je vais en
venir à des utilisations très graves que
le Mali vient de réitérer à l'égard de
la France son ministre des Affaires
étrangères à la tribune des Nations
Unies a accusé la France de complicité
avec certains groupes djihadistes
affirmant que la France livrait des
armes au djihadistes vous étiez
évidemment très impliqué dans tout cela
est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que la
France a eu certaines complicités ou
est-ce que les accusations maliennes
sont farfelues comme le dit la France je
ne peux pas écouter je ne peux pas
défendre la France il se plaint là comme
aussi je ne peux pas soutenir ces
accusations du Mali parce que des
accusations qui me paraissent
invraisemblable dans la mesure de la
France est intervenu pour combattre les
terroristes et la continuer à combattre
l'utérus jusqu'à son départ
donc je trouve que même que c'est des
accusations très très grave qu'il va
falloir quand même prouver et justifier
par la suite c'est que la France est
intervenue au Mali pour arrêter la
pensée des terroristes mais que
effectivement il y a eu des erreurs qui
ont politique qui ont été commises par
la suite
je vais en venir à votre cas vous avez
donc pu quitter la Mauritanie
officiellement pour raison médicale
normalement vous devez être jugé mais
les évidemment se pose la question si on
vous a laissé sortir est-ce que c'est
parce qu'il a une sorte d'accord entre
vous et le pouvoir en place afin
peut-être de vous épargner d'être amené
devant la justice
ce n'est pas ça la réalité je suis dans
une situation d'attente j'attends mon
jugement et je suis prêt à être jugé
parce que pour moi toutes ces
accusations c'est des accusations
fausse qui ne tiennent pas la route qui
ne se justifie pas et qui sont faites
pour des raisons politiques pour
m'empêcher de continuer à faire de la
politique c'est tout et
je ne suis pas je suis en attente je
suis
donc vous n'êtes pas en France vous
n'allez pas demandé l'exil vous allez
rentrer en Mauritanie je ne suis pas un
exilent en France je n'ai pas demandé
d'exil en France et je n'ai pas
rencontré aussi des officiers en France
j'ai juste rencontré des mauritaniers
des membres de ma communauté de la
communauté mauritanienne en France et je
vais retourner d'ici une à deux semaines
en Mauritanie d'ici une à deux semaines
est-ce qu'il y aura un procès d'après
vous est-ce que vous pensez que comme il
y a des échéances électorales mon
souhait c'est qu'il y ait un procès
vraiment
je n'ai jamais refusé à penser j'ai
recréé j'ai refusé mais toutes ces
accusations je refuse les accusations
pour moi je ne tient pas la route et je
suis censé être protégé par l'article 93
de la Constitution mais je tiens à être
jugé pour prouver mon innocence pour
mettre mes accusateurs
devant le fait que je n'ai jamais eu à
détourner quoi que ce soit et je n'ai
jamais été corrompu par qui que ce soit
c'est des accusations fausses qui ne
tiennent pas la route et qui ne sont
basés sur aucun aucune preuve qui n'ont
pas de fonds
ce n'est pas forcément mon système mais
ce sont des gens que j'ai combattis à
l'époque politiquement pour des raisons
dans l'intérêt du parce que vous pensez
que lui cherche peut-être un compromis
avec vous voyant que les choses traînent
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a une
possibilité de compromis je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait une possibilité de compromis
dans des mesures où j'étais accusé
j'ai été d'objet de plusieurs
accusations forces qui ne tiennent pas
la route et je tiens à être jugé pour
que mon essence monnaie son innocence
soit prouvé clairement aux vies et aussi
de tout le monde il y a quand même
quelque chose il y a eu un rapport
parlementaire qui est qui a détaillé bon
vous les fêtes de corruption mais il y a
quand même de l'enrichissement personnel
on parle d'une fortune estimée à 90
millions de dollars sans compter les
biens immobiliers est-ce que vous
comprenez c'est de la siestimation
d'abord et puis c'est une commission qui
a été faite pour m'accuser créer mais
vous ne l'est pas l'enregistrement quand
même
vous n'ayez pas
je n'ai jamais dit que j'étais où je
suis en pauvre j'en ai jamais dit et
j'ai fait ma déclaration de la manière
la plus transparente auprès des
institutions
à charge et mais ce qu'ils ont fait
d'abord la Commission à tenir à
m'accuser à tenir à créer des conditions
c'est de pouvoir exécutif avec avec
certains opposants qui ont tenu à créer
cette commission qui d'abord
ne se justifie pas sur des plans
juridique au niveau de notre
Constitution il n'est pas prévu de
commission d'enquête au niveau de notre
Constitution deuxièmement
toutes ces accusations c'est des actions
qui ne tiennent pas la route
enrichissement illicites
blanchiment d'argent il faudrait que
d'abord l'argent soit sale pour qu'il
soit blanchi d'une part et je n'ai
jamais nié que j'ai de l'argent je n'ai
jamais nié je n'ai jamais nié et j'ai
déclaré que j'ai de l'argent
effectivement et que je ne suis pas un
pauvre je ne suis pas un pauvre mais le
problème est que j'ai été accusé de
corruption il n'y a aucune preuve de
corruption aucune preuve de corruption
que vous êtes prêt et et j'ai été accusé
de
détournement de bien public il n'y a
aucun détournement de bien public il n'y
a aucune structure
l'État qui se plaint d'un détournement
démontant donc vous demandez à juger
vous pensez que la martial je tiens à
être jugé quel que soit la justice de
toute façon je sais qu'il y a de très
bons jeux chez nous s'ils sont laissés à
conscience s'ils sont laissés à la même
mais si on manipule la justice comme ce
qui est fait actuellement la situation
risque de se compliquer je veux en
conclusion on a parlé des coups d'état
vous avez fait des déclarations
récemment disant que ce qui s'était
passé dans des pays comme le Burkina le
Mali ou la Guinée
on ça pourrait éventuellement se passer
en Mauritanie alors est-ce que c'est
un constat ou est-ce que c'est un appel
du pied on sait que le pouvoir vous a
déjà suspecté de fomenter un coup d'État
il y a quelques années je crois que
c'est c'est de la fourberie de la part
de certains
de la fourberie de la part de Paris
pour ne pas dire que c'est une fausse
interprétation de mes propos si on
pousse des populations à la misère à
l'injustice aux privations des droits
Mauritanie alors je vous pose la
question
qui pourrait amener cela j'ai dit qu'il
ne faut rien exclure au vu de ce qui se
passe au pays actuellement je
n'encourage pas des coups d'État parce
que je les ai compatis j'en ai empêché
deux en Mauritanie vous en avez fait
j'en ai fait deux d'ailleurs pour des
raisons pour des raisons pour sauver les
pays et j'ai quitté le pouvoir de la
manière la plus démocratique et la plus
transparente donc je ne peux pas faire
appel au coup d'État chez moi
donc en conclusion vous dites que les
conditions sont réunies pour écouter
d'avoir répondu aux questions de France
24 et merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]